♪ ♪
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETED YESTERDAY.
IF DACA IS PROBABLY DEAD BECAUSE
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T REALLY WANT
IT.
THEY JUST WANT TO TALK AND TAKE
FROM OUR MILITARY.
IF THEY DON'T GET A DEAL
PROTECTING DREAMERS, DEMOCRATS
HAVE THREATENED TO HOLD UP
SPENDING AND THE GOVERNMENT
FUNDING BILL.
NEEDED BY MIDNIGHT ON FRIDAY TO
AVOID THAT SHUTDOWN.
SO WILL THE PRESIDENT CALL THEIR
BLUFF?
SPRING IN JOHN DUFFY IN WAUSAU,
WISCONSIN, AND DARREN SOTO IN
ORLANDO.
CONGRESSMAN SOTO, I WANT TO
START WITH YOU WHEN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON THE SHOW
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT WE
MAKE A REAL EFFORT EVERY DAY TO
GET DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN ON AND
GIVE THEM A FAIR CHANCE, JUST
LIKE WITH REPUBLICANS TO MAKE
THEIR CASE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU, SO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
SEEING YOU.
I'M JUST KIDDING.
WITH YOU.
WILL THE DEMOCRATS REALLY HOLD
UP THE GOVERNMENT FUNDING FOR A
DEAL FOR THE DACA PEOPLE?
>> WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THIS IS A
MOMENT WHERE THE PARTIES CAN
WORK TOGETHER.
WE HAVE GRAHAM AND DURBIN WHO
HAVE COME OUT WITH A BIPARTISAN
PLAN INCLUDING BORDER SECURITY
AS WELL IS HELP FOR OUR
DREAMERS.
OUT THAT WILL GO TO THE HOUSE
FLOOR AND SPEAKER RYAN WILL GIVE
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON IT SO THAT WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT SHUTDOWNS BUT
COMING UP WITH A GENERATIONAL
DEAL TO HELP OUT WITH TWO ISSUES
BOTH PARTIES CARE ABOUT.
>> Laura: BEFORE WE GO TO
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, WHY DO YOU
THINK THAT DURBIN AND GRAHAM
WENT INTO THAT MEETING WITH THE
TWO THINGS THAT THEY KNEW THE
MIGRATION AND OF COURSE THERE
WAS AN ADEQUATE FUNDING THE
WALL.
HE SAID I NEED THIS AND THIS AND
WE WILL DO THIS LEGALIZATION OF
THINGS THAT WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE
IT WORSE.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO START
SOMEWHERE AND THE PRESIDENT CAN
COME BACK WITH WHAT HE PERCEIVES
AS CHAIN MIGRATION AND MAKE A
COUNTER OFFER.
THEN THERE'S THE CONCERN OF THE
WALL.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR
THE WALL IN THE SENATE AND ITS
CONTROVERSIAL IN THE HOUSE.
IT DOESN'T HELP WHERE I'M FROM
IN FLORIDA -- WE CARE ABOUT PORT
SECURITY AND COAST GUARDS' AND
OTHER THINGS.
I THINK OF TO PUT SOMETHING OUT
THERE TO GET A RESPONSE FROM THE
YOU, CONGRESSMAN DUFFY,
SOMETHING THAT BILL CLINTON SAID
BACK IN 1995.
LET'S WATCH.
>> ALL AMERICANS, NOT ONLY THE
STATES MOST HEAVILY AFFECTED,
BUT IN EVERY PLACE IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE RIGHTLY DISTURBED BY
THE LARGE NUMBERS OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS ENTERING OUR COUNTRY.
THE JOBS THEY HOLD MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE HELD BY CITIZENS OR
LEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WE ARE A NATION OF IMMIGRANTS,
BUT WE ARE ALSO A NATION OF LAWS
BUT WE ARE ALSO A NATION OF LAW
LAWS.
IT IS WRONG AND ULTIMATELY
SELF-DEFEATING FOR A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS TO PERMIT THE KIND OF
ABUSE OF OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS WE
HAVE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS, AND
WE MUST DO MORE TO STOP IT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: THE BIPARTISAN
APPLAUSE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE TRUMP,
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
I HAD FORGOTTEN THAT.
OFTEN, BUT I DO TONIGHT.
THIS IS AN EASY SOLUTION AND I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT DARREN IS
ON YOUR HAVING A CONVERSATION
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE HE WANTS TO
GET A DEAL.
THE DEAL THAT WAS PROPOSED IS
THE DEMOCRATS GET EVERYTHING
WHERE YOU GIVE LEGAL STATUS TO
DREAMERS AND YOU GIVE
DONALD TRUMP 10% OF WHAT HE
WANTS, FOR HIS WALL.
WE REVERSE THAT WAS THAT WE WILL
TAKE 10% OF THE DREAMERS, THEY
GET TO STATE AND WE WILL GET
100%, DARREN WOULD BE HERE WITH
HIS HAIR ON FIRE SAYING THAT'S
NOT FAIR.
LET'S CUT A DEAL THAT WORKS FOR
WITH THESE KIDS.
IF THIS IS ABOUT COMPASSION AND
LOVE AND TRUMP TALKS ABOUT THIS
ALL THE TIME.
CERTAINTY TO THE DREAMERS.
IF YOU AND THE NEXT GENERATION
COMING IN.
NOT ONLY THAT, IT'S
COMPASSIONATE FOR AMERICA
BECAUSE WE STOP THE MATH AND
THEY HEROIN IN THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND THE DRUGS THAT
COME OVER AND ACROSS OUR BORDER.
THIS IS A GREAT POLICY THAT
WORKS FOR OUR COUNTRY, FOR
DREAMERS.
I THINK BOTH SIDES CAN CUT A
DEAL BUT YOU HAVE NANCY PELOSI
LEGISLATION AND NOTHING FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
IF THAT STANDOFF LEADS US TO A
POTENTIAL SHUTDOWN ON BEHALF OF
DEMOCRATS.
I THINK IT'S WRONG.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN SOTO,
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING, SOME, A
HANDFUL, THAT THEY WILL NOT COME
TO THE STATE OF THE UNION.
JOHN LEWIS, MAXINE WATERS.
OTHERS SAY DONALD TRUMP IS A
RACIST, WE WILL NOT COUNTENANCE
HIM AS PRESIDENT, BASICALLY HE'S
NOT OUR PRESIDENT AND THEY ARE
NOT COMING.
WHAT DOES THAT DO TO FORGE A
BIPARTISAN DEAL ON THE DREAMERS
OR IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT, THAT
TYPE OF TOXICITY?
>> I CAN'T SPEAK FOR MY COLLEGE.
I WILL BE ATTENDING AND BRINGING
AN EVACUEE FROM PUERTO RICO WHO
IS NOW HERE IN FLORIDA TO
HIGHLIGHT HOW WE STILL DON'T
HAVE POWER DOWN ON THE ISLAND IN
A LOT OF AREAS, BUT I THINK IF
THE SENATE CAN BRING SOMETHING
OVER TO THE HOUSE THAT SEAN AND
SPEAKER RYAN AND OTHERS WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY WILL      T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY WILL      U
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY WILL      T
THEIR TWO CENTS ABOUT WHAT THEY
BUT I THINK WE WILL ALL BE
LISTENING TO THE STATE OF THE
UNION, AT LEAST THOSE OF US IN
ATTENDANCE, TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANY RECONCILIATION MESSAGE OR
RECONCILE -- I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT BUT HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE WITH PEOPLE WHO RUN
OUT OF A MEETING, A PRIVATE
MEETING, AND THEIR EFFORT IS TO
WHIP PEOPLE INTO A RACIAL FRENZY
ABOUT TRUMP?
HOW IS THAT OPERATING IN GOOD
FAITH?
TRUMP DIDN'T SHUT DOWN
NEGOTIATIONS.
JUST SAID I CAN'T DO THAT.
THEY RUSHED OUT AND SAY THE
PRESIDENT IS A RACIST.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO FORGE A
DEAL?
THAT'S JUST NOT GOOD FAITH AT
ALL.
OBVIOUSLY NO ONE KNOWS FOR SURE.
MAYBE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
TO JUST KEEP THAT CLOSE-MINDED,
BUT THEY FELT THE NEED TO SPEAK
OUT.
EITHER WAY, I THINK WE NEED TO
WANT, HELP FOR OUR DREAMERS,
HELP FOR TPS AND HELP FOR BORDER
SECURITY.
I THINK IF WE CAN GET SOMETHING
THROUGH THE SENATE TO THE HOUSE,
LET IT TAKE ITS COURSE AND LET A
BILL GOING TO THE PRESIDENT'S
DESK.
IF HE DOESN'T LIKE IT HE HAS THE
POWER TO VETO IT.
>> Laura: I THINK THE McCALL
BILL, I THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE
BILL, PUSHED BACK TO THE SENATE.